Willie, you beautiful son of a He's going to hit every point.
He's going to He's going to hit every point. >> If you're
a Destiny fan, stop saying that 17 isn't a child. It's really
weird. And trust me, I don't think Destiny appreciates that as
a defense right now. >> He does. He He will take any defense
right now. That's one. Okay, another tiny place where Willy's
wrong. He will take any defense right now. He used to be able
to choose his defenders. He used to be able to make choices.
He used to be able to say, "Don't I don't care if that person
defends me." Right. Wa
buddy. All right. That's not good. That's real bad cuz I think
that would be I believe that would be transferring. No. Wouldn't
that be distributing? Yes. Would that not be distribution? She's
wearing a a DG shirt to me. Shouldn't that mean that like Destiny
should know her name and like shipping information and shouldn't
he be able to look that up? Shouldn't he be able to look that
I bet you we got some CSI analysis on Rose's identity or something,
right? Hyperdoxing Rose again. I I think that could easily be
what we see here. What else? What else? What else? Just basically
uh overview of the laws in Florida and federally.
Some Rose CSI stuff to show that she's actually 17 at the time.
Maybe he'll point out the date on the video titled that Desi
sent him. What else? And then probably just walking through slowly
like what Desi said and showing how it's obvious that at any
point Desi could have gone, "No, no, no. I don't have child born
anymore." And he just refused to do that the whole time. If he
talks about you and Queen, probably not. Probably not. Wait,
what is this? What is this? What is this? Okay. All right. Let's
continue. Let's go. Let's Let's see how this goes video. I broke
allegations on Destiny where in my DMs, he admitted to having
Cam on his computer. Oh, maybe I wonder if he'll talk about the
No, hold on. He has to talk about Destiny saying that Willie
only did this because Nick pushed him that, right? I think I
think he has to address the Nick stuff as well. Did Destiny's
girlfriend he was with at the start of this all this break up
or is she still in the mix? I don't know, man. I I'd heard they
broke it up. That was the last thing I'd heard, but I don't actually
know. You and Cherry 1 v one each other in Civ 7. Nobody plays
Civ 7, so already know. of a 17-year-old named Jez talk pre-watch
during that crappy fake fight. No, I'm just I like making guesses
at stuff. Okay, I just like gambling and sometimes I can say
I think this is going to happen. It's kind of like gambling and
you know
I have an I have god. Okay, I'm I'm compelled to gamble. All
right, and this is a easier form of gambling. It it does away
with my urges with no downside. Okay. Okay, I'm going to hit
play. I'm just grabbing a drink really quickly, but I can hear
>> Hands down the most shocking interaction I've had on
YouTube since things have hit the fan with Destiny and Ethan
going full scorched earth, digging up old Reddit post, going
after family members. Destiny has made a video saying that Rose's
age still hasn't been confirmed. And Aba and Preach uploaded
a video echoing those same claims even though it's not true.
Look, I brought these allegations into this world, and now that
everyone's responded, I want to set the record straight. So when
Destiny's court case with Pixie is over, he could I brought these
allegations into this world. Okay. Uh
>> respond to his most damning accusations in one place
because nobody including me is hoping Destiny has illegal in
his computer, but the receipts against him are ugly and they
need to be addressed. Him deflecting to roses and complaining
about him having nudes of Earth doesn't make it legal. >> I'm
like the only person in the history of the internet who's people
trying to cancel based on no person making any claims against
me. Destiny's first stream back since the allegations went live
against him was to play the song as his stream opening. >> Haters
defend the age of consent. Age is just a number. Jail's just
a place.
>> Every time I make people think it's a sand to thoroughly
rip a kid. >> His Reddit is talking about how he's liking
post on Instagram of little girls being his new girlfriend. Destiny
always has the best optics. I know everybody's a little stressed.
I know everyone's a little tense. >> I didn't even know.
Listen, that's some incredible A-logging right there. Willy's
stepping his game up. I didn't even know that one. >> But
let's just take a deep breath, look at the facts, and use our
sensibilities. And it's made that much easier with Fume. That's
the good stuff. Ever feel like you're stuck in a habit you don't
even think about? Maybe you're >> like 2 hours after Dbing
me now. I understand. I get it. Okay, we have to do the Destiny
bad because we're It's too much heat from other people. >> I
love how he doesn't honestly engage. He just immediately tries
to my character. It's very clear why I went to the police. Wow,
Destiny's not responding to the actual claims. He's just attacking
somebody's character. I wish there was some indication that he
did this before. Huh. Sent me a screenshot of what he described
as videos of a 17-year-old having sex with other guys. His words,
I didn't want to misunderstand him, so I asked very clearly,
"Is the video he just described what he was sending me?" He responded,
"Depends why you're asking?" Which could very obviously be a
joke, but it also implies under the right circumstance he could
have sent this to me. And then he said yes, confirming that he
still has it. When I said that, it's crazy that he was telling
me that he has on his computer. He doesn't deny it. Instead,
he gives reasons for why he's allowed to keep it. >> Yeah.
Uh, this is like the best
This might be the best, most consistently informative opening
to a Willy Mack video I've ever seen. He said like four correct
things in a row. That's baffling. Okay.
>> Stream. He said he was sharing this stuff with other
people to try and find >> Oh, yeah. because I have screenshots
of Yeah, we tried to do identification for some of these videos.
>> Okay, he says he's >> Oh my god, Willy's actually
What? That's like five. Yes, he did say we were trying to find
her. The is we, dude? The is we? And were you are you confirming
that you've been sending these messages or these screenshots
or these videos to other people? >> Analyzing these videos
as in multiple videos, but these videos are cases. I tried to
find her through her boyfriend as well cuz I have screenshots
of when she would record stuff. She literally has a lot of these
were done via Skype calls with her boyfriend which I didn't really
figure at the time. >> How much more clear could it be
that this guy has se on his computer? But fast forward a little
bit and he's tweeting I have no on my computer and saying he
would have worded things differently if he knew I would have
a problem with it. >> I don't know why you talked to Willie
Mac at all. Um I don't remember. >> I don't have any of
these materials
on my computer. I >> think he messaged me on something
but I mean I'd been in communication with him. I just didn't
expect them to. >> It does sound way better in text, right?
You see, I don't have any of these materials on my computer,
but then you hear him say it in in voice and it's like, wait,
why why you guys say it that >> Run and make a YouTube
video in 2 seconds based off some DMs with us. Obviously, the
I would have approached that conversation a lot more care in
terms of how I'm phrasing things obviously. But >> instead
of yes to keeping CS Sam, would you have said no? Cuz that would
obviously change a lot. like your entire statement. He's L. >> If
I if I knew that Willie had a problem with me keeping child porn,
I wouldn't have told him about me keeping child porn. Obviously,
cool. I Uh-huh.
Yeah, I think that's what most child most people who keep child
porn on their computer would say. Yes. Literally rewriting history
in front of our very eyes because saying yes would be a >> Especially
when I have every reason to believe this person. >> Oh
man, I wonder if there's another time where he did that. Like
for example, when he told Straid that yes, he knows he sent that
non-consensually.
Then he didn't leak it. He sent it
>> 19 anyway, so no, he doesn't have every reason to believe
that, especially since Rose's boyfriend, Solo, told him in November
of 2024 that she was 17. Now, to be fair to Destiny, it's not
like Solo is a good guy here. The whole reason why all this drama
started happening with Destiny is because Solo logged into Rose's
Discord account and shared all of the messages between her and
Destiny. This is how we found out Destiny was non-consensually
sharing his nudes of previous partners to a random egirl. But
we only know about it because Solo shared all of this revenge
online. Him doing this has led to a ton of people around Destiny
getting docks. All of this comes from Solo and his main motivation
for doing it is because he was bored. This guy sucks. But this
guy doing these awful things has opened Destiny up to valid criticism.
I've already made two videos talking about the Pixie situation.
Go check that out. If Destiny is upset that this is being brought
up again, he should have never shared those videos with some
random girl over the internet that he didn't even know the age
of responsibility. >> Oh boy. Willie
Willy doesn't understand. Willy's doing some really creepy weird
things right now. Okay. Some really creepy weird behavior that
he's like trying to reset a narrative around Destiny. Doesn't
he know how creepy and weird and fat he's being right now? He's
really fatly laying these out. I sense a lot of fat in these
uh in these arguments being made. Okay. Very creepy, weird, disgusting,
obsessed.
All right, Lily's really Willy's really being gross right now.
>> He lands on him. He's tweeting the 60 GB screenshot
was related to a claim the Rose person made. Someone whose name
and birthday have yet to be reliably >> but this is not
the 60 GB folder or >> And he shows why he knows there's
a 60 GB drive of Rose's underage videos. If you have the size,
you should have it on your PC. It's just a screenshot that she
sent me of the folder. I mean, I could post the screenshot of
what she told me. >> Dude, does he I'll just be real.
When he is trying to address like child allegations, does he
have to do the comb over
like this guy's hair can look okay sometimes? I've seen it look
okay. Why does he pick the comb over for this stream? Can anybody
tell me that? Like this guy's hair can be fine. I just don't
know why he does it. He's balding. I guess it's just crazy.
Never mind. We figured it out. Dress for the job you want, not
the one you have. Sam hacks mine and my boyfriend's cloud storage.
They will find a treasure trove. I swear I have 310 folders of
photo sets. Total size 61.15
GB. >> But the context of her sending Destiny this is that
she would send him those videos that her boyfriend recorded.
She told him, "I'll see if I can salvage any of these recordings
my boyfriend made for you." Destiny then sent me a screenshot
of a video he has open and describes it as an underage video
Rose sent him. Her boyfriend was recording these on Skype calls.
That's absolutely insane to think about him doing all of this
if she was 17. He's describing and acknowledging that he has
I blatantly asked him and he answers yes, giving reasons why
he could keep it on his >> Okay, I'm gonna do I'm
best impression. Okay. So, I would say it's a blatant understanding
that she could be 17. All right, which is there's not a lot of
wiggle room here. This is actually one of the better videos Willy's
ever done. He is saying that he it would be insane if she was
17, but I don't know if Destiny realizes this. Other people are
capable of making decisions almost as bad as his decisions. Okay,
if this wasn't, why didn't he deny it? Uh, no. Oh, he's saying
that like if she is 17 as these are people are alleging, it's
insane to think that Solo did this, but it's like him tacitly
admitting that this could be child and thus he should be treating
it like child,
right? Sorry, Willy's not off point here enough to like actually
weasel around. I'm just laughing at like how Desi would have
to try to weasel through these situations to make it make any
sense at all. told this if she was 17. He's describing and acknowledging
that he has I blatantly asked him and he answers yes, giving
reasons why he could keep it on his computer. When he pulls it
up on screen, he acknowledges that this is that solo recorded
of her. >> Cuz I have screenshots of when she would record
stuff. She literally has um a lot of these were done via Skype
calls with her boyfriend, which I didn't really figure at the
time, but we tried to find out who the boyfriend was based on
initials and stuff from here, too. But this is not the 60 GB
folder or whatever. Not. >> Oh, if Willie analyzes that
date. Okay. The lol dubbies while disclosing you're in possession
of is actually Kino. >> It's just one
>> It's such an incredible I It's so It's so crazy folder
or whatever. >> No, it's just one gigabyte of He's lying
when he's saying this is an uncharitable reading. These are very
direct. >> Oh, you're talking about in here. Yeah, L.
That's just an absolutely insane thing to think uh uh think about
him doing all of this if she was 17. Lil W.
Little W.
Little W. This is unironically like I realize I'm basically committing
like a crime right now. Lil W. Wouldn't it be crazy if this guy
committed a crime that I'm committing a crime? Lil W. Questions.
If you're saying this to me, I'm guessing you still have the
video. L W but yes. L W but yes. >> And he's giving very
direct answers. Yet his viewers cope in mess. But he didn't do
that. Are you really going to be this dishonest? Somebody directly
shows him that he did say yes to having >> That's awesome
that Willie Mack is referencing Well, Lighthouse. All right.
Well known well-known Jtock Reply guy. Well, Lighthouse. I think
he's actually a Mr. Girl fan. Okay. This guy is I think he's
actually like a Big Max fan, but yeah, he's uh he's usually there.
He's usually got the facts on his side. All right. >> P.
And then it becomes well, he was just making general statements.
It's not general at all. It's actually very specific statement.
Comes Willy was what was it? He's making Does Willy realize that
by putting this in his video, he's probably like getting these
people docked somehow. Willy realize that that pointing out that
Destiny's audience is unhinged and he deploys them to muddy the
water for muddy the waters for him and that that's pretty crazy
in and of itself. Does he realize he's maybe getting this guy
doxed? That's up, isn't it? That's why we love him, Izzy, Mandius.
Okay. Well, Lighthouse is always there. He's always watching.
He's just making general statements. It's not general at all.
It's actually very specific statements. Destiny viewers, these
DMs are your Emperor has no clothes moment and you were choosing
to be blind. Just to be clear, the DMs with Straighter Aid were
already an Emperor has no clothes moment. If you looked at those
DMs with Straighter and go, "No, I believe that he's actually
just apologizing for anybody leaking those for any reason." And
and when he says that he violated her trust in the worst way
ever, he just means like because these eventually got leaked
somehow totally out of his control. That he doesn't mean that
he like, "Yeah, did did send them non-consensually and he totally
violated her trust." He doesn't mean that, right? That was the
Emperor has no clothes moment. This is like um this is something
scarier. This is like the Jonestown moment, okay? Like this is
like you all watch Destiny put the poison in the punch and he
hands you a glass and you're like, "Bottoms up, buddy. Let's
go." And you just knock it back, right? Hold him to a higher
standard. As far as Rose's age goes, it has been confirmed since
August 20th. This is due to Destiny posting information about
her college to Mckiwi Farm's failed attempts to dox her. Well,
they found her and she's wearing Destiny's merch. Same girl from
the Twitter account. >> This guy just rolls these pictures
out with no concern. >> So, that is the picture that I
didn't want to show. Now, I think that's just a little I think
that's just a little weird. I'm going to pause here for a quick
second. Oh, he just
found the >> Dude, I just I'm gonna chill for a second.
He is just gonna throw all of it out here. That's uh I
check mark off for me. Okay.
No, she's not a minor anymore. He's just doxing an an adult.
Okay, dude. Uh, what's this? Zoom. I'm trying to zoom so that
it's only the the blurred name here. I'll move it down a little
bit. What am I trying to say here? Oh, in that picture.
So, she's wearing a a DG shirt to me. Shouldn't that mean that
like Destiny should know her name and like shipping information
and [__] Shouldn't he be able to look that up? Shouldn't
he be able to look that up? Also, that was the thing where I
feel like in a context where a girl sending you a picture of
like a shirt you
like when it's your merch or when it's your shirt with no other
clothes on that you can see, I feel like that's always like slightly
intimate and to suggest otherwise a little silly. Tom Fery said
that was a crazy opinion that that photo could be considered
slightly lewd because uh
she's like not wearing it. You can't see anything else she's
wearing. I don't think that's crazy to be honest. No, no, no,
no, no. Just to be clear, like he is posting those pictures.
I think it's a little weird, but I don't know. Anyway, let's
uh let's see. >> Same girl living in the same town because
of this local news clip. And her birthday is October of 2004.
This is confirmed again with a traffic violation, and she's the
only person with that name in that town. And she Oh, fits that
exact Okay. I like it. It's up there now. It's up there now.
Whatever.
Cuz I unfortunately it's like out there now. I'm I'm actually
just going to walk through this. It's out there. Lily's posted
it twice. I'm probably not doing anything worse than Lily's doing,
right? >> I It's It's out there at this point. >> I'm
just gonna walk through this about her college to >> Yes,
Destiny. Oh, look. He's using I recognize these screenshots.
Willie Max fan, guys. I did this blurring myself. I did this
blurring myself so that I could protect and not show the links
to these things. I just wanted to show that he had posted it.
Right. I like that he's using my blurred screenshots and then
just showing the things this blurred screenshots lead to because
this is her. This is like Rock Valley College the thing he shows
and these are the pictures. Did he credit you? No, but I don't
care. >> Failed attempts to dox her. Well, they found her
and she's wearing Destiny's
>> So, yes, it's Destiny's merch. Uh, this is a bigger
picture where you can see like she's not wearing anything other
than the shirt, right? Seriously, what is the point? >> Same
girl from the Twitter account. They found her name listed among
college peers. They found the same girl living in the same town
because of the
>> Okay. local news clip and her birthday >> Yes.
So, there's multiple different places with public records that
show her age. Okay. Multiple different places.
Um
there's multiple different places that show uh or not multiple,
there's there's a whole other thing where somebody who is suing
her for her running a red light and hitting them says her age
on a specific date, right? to confirm that like the person born
in that it's like her again. There's like so many different individual
pieces of evidence that show that this is who she is, that this
is her birthday.
And then you put this together with the fact that it's August
2022 in the video that Desi sends the screenshot of and that's
how you know for a fact that he was in possession of child. Okay,
it's not disputable. It's not even remotely disputable. It's
obvious. October of 2004. This is confirmed again with a traffic
violation and she's the only person with that name in that town
and she fits that exact description. >> Why do you post
the college name? I don't know why he did that. >> Meaning
that when Destiny was sending and receiving material from her,
she was underage. The video that Destiny showed me he still has
is titled with the date of August 14th. Oh, Willy did somebody's
been watching my stream for the analysis. Let's go. Or, you know,
any of the other streams of people with, you know, an IQ above
95. Somebody's been watching at least one of the streams for
the analysis here and can see that obviously.
All right, she was underage in this video
in here right now. Say hi. This is by far the best video I've
seen from Lily so far. Like I'm I'm watching this. This is actually
like tight. I don't like the that he put the information out.
But also, here's the thing. When you don't post that information,
right? When you don't do what Willie just did, as much as I don't
like it, that's what Destiny prays on, right? When you don't
post everything and show that there is categorically zero ways
to deny this, Destiny operates on that. And he will go and he
will say that this isn't proven. Oh, there's not really any evidence,
right?
So, it is kind of [__] up that like Destiny literally
forces this situation to happen. He forces it. Test is going
to have to smear Willie as a doctor now. I guess we'll see. We'll
see.
I did notice died. I didn't want to point it out. Okay. >> 2022,
meaning she was 17 in that video. That is illegal. Upon telling
them that she's a minor, no reason to think the docs is wrong.
Destiny doesn't go, "Oh, I better turn this over to authorities."
He replies with why he thinks he should still keep it. He doesn't
even know for a fact. I don't think I'm allowed to delete it.
I don't know if it counts as hiding or destroying evidence. I'm
pretty sure I have an obligation to
the Twitch politics. The Twitch politics totally
told him Dan Saltman told Destiny, right? Stop speaking and hedging
every single thing you say because it makes you look like a weirdo
like to people, right? I'm pretty sure I can keep this child.
I'm pretty sure I I'm pretty sure I'm allowed to keep this child.
I think maybe I'm allowed to keep this child. Looks really bad.
You should probably have a good definitive idea of whether or
not you told your lawyers about this, right? >> Serve this
stuff. This is not someone who's confident they're doing the
right thing. Destiny says he could keep it because of his court
case with Pixie. >> Now, he spends time going through this
Rose person who supposedly KBI Farms has dug up stuff about.
Um, I haven't been able to verify the authenticity. Nobody close
to me has been able to verify the >> Literally, anybody
can verify its authenticity right now. But Aban Preach blindly
repeat Destiny. You could say, >> "Oh god, he's actually
Oh, I might have to say Willie W after this video. This is so
up. I didn't think this could occur.
I didn't think this could occur.
This is actually a good Willie video. >> Destiny's irresponsible."
You can say a lot of things, but first off, the person's age
hasn't been confirmed. >> False. Just because you're too
lazy to look doesn't mean that. >> Secondly, you guys are
all admitting that Destiny didn't know the person's age at the
time until years later. And that's only the alleged age. >> If
somebody tells you that you have nudes of an alleged minor, are
you going to keep them? What kind of commentary is this? This
is crazy. >> If you don't see why him having a court case
where this is reent and his lawyer tells him not to delete it
doesn't,
Dude, I didn't even necessarily want to go over this video cuz
I did not want to have to point out how stupid these arguments
were. Uh I'm just going to trust Destiny and uh he said his lawyer
told him to keep that job. So, you know what? I I totally believe
that actually matter like I don't No, I think you guys are a
bit bit too much. >> Rose's nudes are not related to his
court case. His court case is about him sharing Pixie's nudes
with Rose and Solo informed him that Rose might be a minor 2
months before any court case started. I've been preach blindly
agree that yeah, Destiny's lawyer. >> Another fantastic
point. >> Would have told him to keep CS Sam for his. By
the way, I'll just point out I still hate Willie Mac. I still
hate this guy for like a bunch of different personal reasons,
okay? But this video is like objectively good.
It's a great video so far. >> Legal case, but what is your
source? I haven't seen one lawyer covering this that agrees with
that. >> This person was factually underage, therefore
this is factually seasick.
That completely changes the dynamic from something the lawyer
might not have to report because he doesn't know one way or another
to something he'd say, "Well, now we've got to talk about this.
Now we've got to disclose this to the court." I'm just saying
and presenting out there as always professionally, hey, here's
the the attack. Here's the defense, right? And it doesn't look
good for Destiny. This does not look good. This is in addition
to his civil >> Oh, man. This this part the negate child
element. So this part where he has to maintain that she's I almost
wonder if
could there have been a hypothetical
where he asked Andrew Breler hypothetically if this were C and
we wanted to be able to like not have to get the negative uh
what is it like the the negative inference penalty on deleting
evidence from these DMs. If we wanted to not get that negative
inference penalty,
I'd have to believe she was 18 the whole time, right? And I almost
wonder if it's the fact that they don't want the negative inference
penalty of deleting these videos, right?
And so they wanted to keep them in there. They didn't want to
acknowledge that they might have known she was under 18,
right? I kind of wonder if like that if that's like they've been
going with this plausible deniability thing. Moody Morgan, you
are a [__] Did Willie Max suddenly not slander me
or Queman? Did he suddenly not lie to make that whole video basing
it only on Desty's opinion? Shut the [__] up, loser.
Okay. Uh, until something changes there. No. Every reason I dislike
Willie Mack for is still valid. Just because he makes one video
doesn't make it okay that he did all those things before. Shut
up.
Right. And it doesn't look good for Destiny. This does not look
good. This is in addition to his civil case. So, this has gone
for something that is >> No. No. Zezy sidewalk chalk. I
said this is a great Willie video. This is the best Willie video
I've ever seen. He has not missed a point yet. I'm telling you
that despite me hating Willie, I can point out that this video
is fantastic. It's hitting every single point. This is a great
video. >> Purely civil to something that is now potentially
criminal. >> Napoleon Fezer says 17, that's illegal, but
hardly it's child.
You cannot have pictures of minors.
It doesn't matter if the age of consent is 16. Like here in Ohio,
you could a 16-year-old. You can't have naked pictures of them
if they're under 18. No, you're done. He says, I don't think
I'm allowed to delete it. I don't know if it counts as hiding
or destroying evidence. So, here's the deal. Notice what Destiny
isn't telling you. My attorney told me to do this because I guarantee
you, he hasn't told his attorney, "Hey, I've got child kicking
around on my computer. What do I do about that?" There's a discovery
demand and he has to turn that over. Pixie can't hold on to it.
Like I said, Pixie her attorneys. No, you like childies like
Chernobyl graphite, you guys. You can't touch it. How does Discovery
happen? Well, it'll happen with what Pixie and Destiny have done
or other things Destiny has done, but the child that doesn't
need to be in there. >> You can do everything else. Did
Destiny send Pixie's pictures out without permission? That's
all we're really worried about right now. >> So, what research?
What lawyers did Abbe and Preach go to before spouting off all
of this? They cited nothing and then just declared that I'm in
the wrong. The video ends in such a bizarre way. >> You
can say he's irresponsible. You can say that's stupid. You can
say maybe he should turn it in, but to make that video and make
it seem like it's something it's not. >> What do you mean
by maybe he should turn it in? Bro, it's He has to turn it in.
What a shocking video. ABBA claims Destiny already reported this
to >> What are we talking about? There's an ongoing legal
matter. He submitted this evidence to authorities. >> No,
he didn't. Destiny said he was going to on behalf of Pixie. And
do you know what I think happened here, right? I think I think
I'm not totally sure. I think that they might have turned over
all of the DMs, all of the files and from this to Pixie side,
right? That that seems like it cuz Tom said it and I'm guessing
Tom Abba, a couple of the people. I'm guessing Destiny said this.
Oh, I turned it over to them already. I don't know if that makes
things better for him, especially if he had reason to believe
that it was at the time. And he did. He did. If he turned it
over to them and he had a reason to believe it was, oh boy. Oh,
buddy. As the Kino Casino guys would say. Okay. As the PPP guy
would say,
buddy. All right. That's not good. That's real bad cuz I think
that would be I believe that would be transferring. No. Wouldn't
that be distributing? Yes. Would that not be distribution? That'd
be pretty bad. Yo, Wes, what's up, buddy? How's it going? How
goes? How goes?
You thought Pixie's lawyers were speaking, spuring before,
you ain't seen nothing yet. What's up, Wes? We're watching a
video um basically explaining exactly why Destiny was retaining
child on his computer. Do you know Desi confessed to having child
in his computer? It's been a rough couple weeks for for Destiny.
I know you've been kind of tapped out a little bit, Wes, but
it's not been great. We're uh we're just checking it out. That
was the whole If you heard about Destiny possibly being a Yeah,
it's uh not like a he's like seeking out like 10year-olds, but
yeah, he definitely had and kind of knew he had like a 17-year-old.
It's a little [__] up. Anyway, let's continue. >> Then
stop when she decided to sue him. >> Are you going to report
it to the FBI? Uh maybe the when I was doing work with the New
York law firm, the goal was initially because the packet that
we put together was um a thing that we were I think I I don't
remember if I said the original packet was going to the DOJ.
That was the goal of that originally because I thought that the
the stuff that the solo guy
are you going to report this to somebody? Well, you see actually
when I originally retained a law firm and and we were putting
together a packet of information that we were going to send to
the DOJ and you know originally this is our plan.
Brother, the answer is yeah. As soon as I found out about this,
I'm going to report it to the police. Yes. Yes, I'm going to
report it. Obviously, >> even if the girl isn't underage
was um criminal in behavior one trillion%. Goal initially was
just was to send it all to the to the DOJ and then have them
try to pursue it there. >> As far as I know, he never followed
through with this. Everyone, including professionals, is saying
there's no shot he told his lawyer that this was. So, to me,
it clearly seems like he's lying. If you want to interpret my
messages in the worst way possible and you want to and that's
going to be the basis for some FBI call. >> I I know Destiny
um cuz I I I was griffing a little early on this. He streamed
today and he was saying, "Oh, Willie Mack misread what I was
saying." I'm like there's there's no miscalculation there. And
like if you were that incorrect in your words and you're not
that
is this like are you sure you have child? Yes, I'm I think I'm
allowed to keep it. Are you sure you have child? Yeah, I'm pretty
sure my lawyer said I should keep it. Are you sure you have child?
Yes, I I I've got a screenshot. I Yeah. Okay. Destiny the next
day. No, I misspoke. I misspoke. I Why are you Why are you holding
that against me? That's stupid. Destiny's pretty eloquent when
he needs to be. >> Yeah, I I you know, how do you accidentally
say, you know, I got more cheese pizza than Papa John's? I was
having like I was starting to have a bit of a panic attack. like
he's laying out I've got it and this idea that I have to save
it. >> So I said if Destiny wants to prove people wrong,
he should get a public statement of his lawyer explaining this.
He is not currently in a court case over Rose's material. It
would be such an easy win to clear things up. But no, he writes
it off as an impossibility. >> I think he should probably
get on stream with his legal counsel and have them explain why
having alleged CV since November is okay in this instance and
legal. I've never seen one lawyer agree with this for I don't
know how [__] you have to be to think that one that
any lawyer would ever agree to do this. >> Companies have
lawyers write up statements for them all the time. And if you
went to the police, he should show a report. If he just does
either of these things, he's in the clear. So why doesn't he
just do them? He skipped the entire point of H3's video. The
majority of it he dodged. He won't even provide the quote unquote
good faith interpretations of the messages he sent. I've seen
Destiny when he's in the right, he usually directly confronts
it and brings receipts here.
>> He's just constantly deflecting. He's like, "Look at
all these edgy jokes Ethan made in the past." >> We went
around from channel to channel like around like it was horrible.
We went to this channel with this like this kid was like 8 years
old and he was growing out with everybody. >> Dude, I can't
listen.
If Willie could only make one good video in his entire life,
I'm glad it's this one. Okay. I I am glad it's this one. Okay.
If he only had one good video of him his entire YouTube career,
I'm psyched. It's this >> In this chat, for whatever reason,
this kid decides to take his pants off and wiggle his 8-year-old.
I can't even believe it. >> I haven't gotten into Ethan's
jokes yet, but I do think it's kind of funny that I feel like
I've heard him say similar
>> It's called Children's Joy TV for a reason. The guy
knows how to give pleasure children. Children's Joy TV. baby
gets by a syringe and gets >> Bro, why is why is Willie
playing the full like the full Ethan clips >> injected
with AIDS virus >> when we see something like this so weird
>> he's just taking shots at Ethan for no >> I feel
like I'm definitely >> he's on Ethan side
>> I don't know how many FBI watch list jokes he's made
he is maybe he isn't but if again if like that's the standard
then sure >> bro you watched a real video of an 8-year-old
shaking his These are not the same also I would look at some
of Ethan's old edgy jokes a bit differently if he admitted to
having to another content creator, but he didn't. You did, and
now people are raising eyebrows. Ethan points out how Destiny
defending Vosch for getting off to Loi feels creepier now. >> Who
the cares about Loi? Who cares about drawn? Imagine your life
is so boring that you give a about animated cartoon >> Imagine
your life so boring that you care about children. Imagine being
so bored in your life that you actually care if grown-ups want
to minor. >> Destiny doesn't really engage. He doesn't
defend his position. Instead, he goes after Ethan for laughing
at Rick and Morty. Smut. >> Rick and Morty.
>> No way. That's on That's Rick and
>> this is No, I I think this is a fair point on hypocrisy.
Hypocrisy doesn't help Destiny, right? Ethan could be the biggest
hypocrite in the world. Destiny is still holding on to child.
It doesn't matter how big a hypocrite Ethan is. But this is absolute
hypocrisy. This is a character who's a minor that they're looking
at like uh some kind of like depiction of >> Yeah. This
is from an episode of Rick and Morty where Mr. Mees runs train
on >> Mr. Mees and all his >> I don't know why Willy's
including all of it. It's kind of funny though. >> He's
not I can see. >> So he is now. Okay. Do I actually think
he's getting off to Lcon or that he enjoys this despite that
creepy smile he has while sharing his
hentai with his parents? Probably not. But like is this is this
if this is the standard we're going to use? I mean Jesus Christ.
>> Obviously laughing at the absurdity of degenerate stuff
is not the same as getting off to it. But Destiny's not here
to make sense. He's here to go scorched earth. He plays a bunch
of clips of Ethan making fun of cringe and creepy videos online.
Leaves out all the context. Both of these guys definitely make
their share of inappropriate jokes, but with Destiny, it's just
different. His are coming from leaked group chats. >> He
then shared this LWD, >> this is not a joke, >> image
of a child with his friends and said that he's going to get arrested
>> There's a a picture of a 15-year-old in a bikini who's
saying is hot. Girl on the left, so hard to say no. gonna get
arrested one of these MLGs. Man, the way he represents this to
people in his audience, I was just warning them about how dangerous
it is that like there are minors in the MLG audience and like
they could they could fall victim. They could fall victim just
like I almost fell victim. I'm totally not just saying they're
hot and that I'm like borderline I'm borderline considering going
to jail to this 15-year-old. That's not what I'm saying at all,
guys. Hey, >> imagine receiving a bikini pic from a 15-year-old
in your DMs, a fan of yours, and being like, "She's so hot. I
need to share this with the boys." >> His friend asks,
"Picks, please." And Destiny sends what was a public Instagram
photo of her in a bikini. And goes, "Girl on the left. So hard
to say no. I'm going to get arrested one of these MLGs, man."
His friend replies, "Who cares? It's not like you're 40." Destiny
tries to recontextualize this as him warning his friends to watch
out. Oh,
Willie,
you beautiful son of a [__] You beautiful son of
a [__]
He's going to hit every point. He's going to hit he's going to
hit every >> Who cares? It's not like you're 40. Destiny
tries to recontextualize this as him warning his friends to watch
out for jail bit. >> Yeah, I messaged my little team or
whatever. Obviously, those DMs were pretty crass, but I mean
the whole point is like, hey, like there are going to be people
that DM you. They'll send you pictures. They look older than
they actually are. Don't minor. Your life is going to be over.
Don't do it. But these logs are >> Hold on. Hold on. This
a DJ in chat. Uh he didn't say he was the one warning people
at MLG. He just said the people running MLG events were warning
the pro players. Just FYI.
>> To watch out for jail a bit. >> Yeah, I messaged
my little team or whatever. Obviously those DMs were pretty crass,
but I mean the whole point is like, hey, like there are going
to be people that DM you. They'll send you >> Oh, so that's
like exactly that's like
him saying that he was he was warning people. That's him saying
he's the one warning people. Just to be clear, this Jayce's guy,
okay, you just said the opposite of what reality is because you
are a cult. Like you you you just watched him say explicitly
from his point of view that he is warning people about this.
You're
I h we're winning so much than they actually are. >> God,
isn't it just such a It's the whole last week it's just been
win after win after win. This is a week so good even Willy Max
get breaking a 100 IQ points. Dude, it's win after win after
win. >> Don't minor. Your life is going to be over. Don't
do it. >> But these logs are public. You can see that they
were just gooning. There's no speech about being careful for
jailbait. It's about them banging stars and stuff. These messages
are real. Destiny has confirmed it. >> You don't need screenshots.
There should be a pay spin of the entire >> Now, I don't
want to give a whole lot of credence to this because Destiny
did not hook up with a 15-year-old. As one of his friends said,
it's not worth it. I do raise my eyebrows though that one of
their reasons to not do it is because they're inexperienced in
bed. Destiny saying this is a group check. >> Wait, what?
>> One of their reasons to not do it is because they're
inex.
>> Problem is, after you've banged more than like three
chicks, banging hot chicks who suck at bed is no fun anymore.
I think hooked up with a 17-year-old and they're usually so
Damn it. >> In bed. Destiny saying this is a group chat
conversation to warn people about the dangers of jailbait. It's
just a lie. They're just exchanging stories. You can be as good
faith or bad faith as you want with this stuff. At one point,
Ethan plays a clip of Destiny saying that 19-year-olds might
as well be children to him. And I think Ethan completely misunderstands
this clip. It's Destiny saying people should not hook up with
19year-olds because they are basically still children to him.
>> I'm 29. A 19-year-old might as well be a 15-year-old
to me. It's all the same, dude. Don't give me this. Just >> have
such an interesting subject. >> This is exactly what we're
saying. >> It's all the same, bro. 15, 13, 14, 15. It's
all the same, bro. I'm 29. Also, on the other hand, it also is
um a self-report because it suggests he knows exactly what he's
doing. >> If you listen to the actual debate here, I'm
arguing with a dude who is literally trying to abduct a mentally
19-year-old and take her to another state and impregnate her.
Basically, every other time I'm speaking about this person underage.
I do refer to the fact they're 19, but it's not just the fact
they're 19. There's a whole bunch of other things, too. >> Yes,
Destiny did have this debate, but at this point in the stream,
Destiny was just generally speaking to his audience. He even
goes on to say that his 20-year-old viewers don't realize how
young they are. >> Now, I know if you're 20 years old,
it might bother you to hear that. like, "No, I'm 19. I'm a real
adult." Okay? I'm a real adult. Okay? If your mom and dad, if
you live with your mom and dad, your mom and dad still pay all
of your bills. You've never even had a job before. You've never
lived on your own. You're a child. You're very much a child.
You don't know what it's like to wake up and go into work to
work a job you hate because you have to pay a bill. Okay? You
don't know what it's like to have to make a decision between
getting kind of a cool car and a piece of car because you can't
afford it. You don't know what it's like to get called in to
have to work an extra shift because you don't, right? You don't
have any life experience. You don't know anything about anything.
You're a child. So all the people in chat, they're like, "No,
19 years old, that's an adult. That's an adult dog." No.
No. >> So when it comes out that he's Rose when he's 33,
it's like, "What the hell?" Rose, even when Destiny thought she
was 19, fit all of this criteria. >> Oh god, there's no
way that he's going to uh Oh, is he going to go to the Twitter
DM? So, this is the part of the um this is the part of the Twitter
DMs that Destiny I I think is corroborated by some leaks that
were posted on Kiwi Farms. Okay, maybe he'll go there. I also
think there's no way we get out of this if he's been if he's
really been watching or somebody who's writing for him has been
watching the streams, watch any of the streams on this, he's
going to get the the Dia clip, too, right? He's got to get the
Dia clip, too. >> All he does is deflect. What about Solo?
What about Ethan's meme Reddit account? By the way, >> all
of this criteria all he does. >> By the way,
the whole thing has been so boring because the omega levels of
sweeping by Jtock Chudman
the flight. What about Solo? What about Ethan's meme Reddit account?
What about Ethan's dad dating his mom at 21 when she was only
16? Really? You're going to bring family into this when your
own kid is saying crazy stuff about you on the internet? This
drama is so scorched earth. Destiny's audience made this graphic
to make fun of how Assan never engages with criticism. This perfectly
applies to Destiny right now. Hide. He hides beyond the fact
that some of the details come from Kiwi Farms when it just doesn't
matter. Verified information is still verified information no
matter where it comes >> I'm not I'm not going to sit here
and listen to him opine on all of the on on his theories here.
>> Alter. He lies about the substance of the messages claiming
he never admitted to keeping even though it's in text. Straw
man, make fun of me. O dude, he's
he's actually documenting talking to the police. try and act
like Ethan's a hypocrite for making edgy jokes when the situation
is not the same and it certainly doesn't alleviate him from what
he's done wrong. Avoid. He hinges on small details to avoid the
actual allegations like how he doesn't have all 60 GB of Cam
when the concerning part is that he does have at least some of
that >> Like there's a whole bunch of like weird lies that
came out of the Willie Mack video. People were saying like I
have 60 gigabyte folders. I'm like this is not true. It's like
an obvious misreading of a message that Willie Mac is showing
on >> And then finally name call. Meme your way out of
this. Act like none of this is a big deal. Destiny knew that
if Rose turned out to be underage, it would be a big deal. Even
saying if Rose was legit a minor, I'm probably done. I can >> I've
Oh, this is uh this goes the other >> Sweep and meme through
basically anything. Even though >> Okay, there's the there's
a finally there's a mistake. Okay, I was >> some of it
is really doing the Donald Trump. I could get away with murder.
>> They say I have the most loyal people. Did you ever
see that >> tiniest little mistake? We don't even hold
that one against >> where I could stand in the middle of
Fifth Avenue and somebody and I wouldn't lose any voters. Okay,
it's like >> So, I think there's three ways this situation
went down here. One is that Destiny really didn't believe Solo
when he said Rose was 17. >> Uh, this is very possible.
I didn't believe Solo. I don't think it's that weird to think
Solo's lying. I think it's incumbent on you to figure that the
out and talk to a lawyer probably at that point or talk to the
cops. Do whatever you got to do to like make sure you're covered.
He kept the picture in logs just in case he got into legal trouble
over the leaks, which he did with Pixie. And then when Rose was
doxed, confirming she was 17. Destiny was more focused on how
Solo would be in the wrong than himself, sharing with me that
he still has the material when I was obviously unhappy with him
asking why he still has on his computer. Destiny spoke out of
his ass, making up that his lawyer told him to keep it, and why
he now keeps saying that Rose's age hasn't been confirmed when
it clearly has been. And then when I went public, he panicked
and called me a liar, changing his story, saying I'm being bad
faith because otherwise he'd be admitting to a felony. This would
be good because that means Destiny isn't a and he just mishandled
this whole thing. It is a messy situation for sure. Option two
is Destiny handled everything perfectly. And to prove it, all
he would need is a statement from his lawyer saying that he acted
accordingly while holding on to the sea. Nobody thinks this is
possible, including other legal professionals. But if it is,
Destiny should do it. I will delete my video and apologize if
it is true. Or option three. Oh,
>> he's a creep. Would really explain his take on Dr. Disrespect
who was planning on meeting up with a minor. >> If some
chick if some 17-year-old girl is DMing Dr. She's like, "Hey,
we should go to kind of like, yeah, I'm going to whatever." Uh,
I probably shouldn't do it. She's young. That's stupid. But I
just don't really give that much. I think it's I don't think
anybody actually cares. I don't give a if they want to do it.
I don't care. I at this point I just don't give a about any of
that [__] Nickelos.
>> I want to end this video by touching on a few things.
If you're a Destiny fan, stop saying that 17 isn't a child. It's
really weird. And trust me, I don't think Destiny appreciates
that as a defense right now. He does. He He will take any defense
right now. That's what Okay, another tiny place where Willy's
wrong. He will take any defense right now. He used to be able
to choose his defenders. He used to be able to make choices.
He used to be able to say, "Don't I don't care if that person
defends me." Right. No, he needs any defense he can get right
now. Okay, he's he's deploying DJs. He's saying you guys just
go say whatever you can, okay? I need anybody sweeping. I don't
care >> People have been critical of me for making a video
after reporting Destiny to the police. He absolutely torched
me for this. >> The fact that you would then publish a
video on it. Um, again, I don't want to dive into the injuries
all this, but Oh, if Willie had a bit of that thing where he
asked, "Can I announce this publicly?" And they said, "Yeah,
go ahead." or something.
That's like the end. And that's like the final the >> You
must understand that by doing that you are literally undermining
every single thing that you're attempting to do. What like why
the would you publish a video on that? You must understand how
be beyond stupid that is if everything that you were alleging
was true. How [__] would that be? Why would you do
that? All of this was done over the internet. Nothing is truly
deleted. He's already said he's kept everything in case there's
a criminal investigation. He'd literally have to smelt his hard
drive. So, I don't think I sabotaged any potential investigation,
but at the same time, I don't even know if there will be an investigation.
That's up to authorities. So, I'm also thinking about at what
point does the public have the right to know about this? I don't
know. I'm definitely open to criticism. I think I handled it
how most media outlets would. I'm also just hoping
I think he could have waited and checked with the cops. If he
checked with the cops and said, "Hey, I want to make a video
on this. I'm a content creator." And they said, "Yes, I think
you should check with the cops." But honestly, given how good
the rest of the video was, I'm not going to har >> Nobody
tells me that they have seam ever again. Also, I don't know if
Destiny will be charged. It's not up to me or Ethan. It's up
to the prosecutors for how they want to handle this. >> It's
really up to prosecutors what they're thinking about, what they
go for. That's not in the control of any streamer. It's not in
control of Ethan Klein or Hassan or anybody else. It's in the
control of the prosecutors to decide, hey, why why are we going
to how are we going to go after Destiny? If we go after Destiny,
that's up to them. So, do I think Destiny is a It entirely comes
down to how charitable you want to be towards him. Do you think
these clips show a dark pattern of behavior? I just come back
to if Destiny was really following the advice of his legal counsel,
he should get a statement from them. It will clear all of this
up. If he's mishandled everything, he should take it to authority.
Oh, the funny thing is is what we're going to get if if Destiny
did go this route, it would be like we advise Destiny based on
what he told us to like retain the files. It'll be something
like that, right? and it won't really resolve
whether or not he was clear about this he's now and this is kind
of where we're at until his court case concludes or he's criminally
investigated. He did say when that's over though he'd go on the
H3 podcast so we will eventually get answers. How unhoused can
it get? Tune in next time by subscribing to the channel. Shout
out to the homies over on Patreon who have access to our exclusive
Discord. Thank you, Crimson Glad. >> Okay, you know what?
You know what? I I straight up I do not like this guy. Okay,
there's a lot of different reasons, but he earned
me entertaining his vape pen advertisement. Take a >> breath,
look at the facts, and use our sensibilities, and it's made that
much >> I'll actually watch it.
>> that's the good stuff. Ever feel like you're stuck in
a habit you don't even think about? Maybe you're reaching for
something when you're hanging out with friends or in stressful
moments or just out of boredom. This isn't a vape, Eig, or nicotine
product. It's something totally different without inhaling anything
harmful. Fume is just flavored air and gives you something to
reach for without all the harmful chemicals. And it comes in
a wide variety of flavors. But my favorite part about Fume is
it's the greatest adult fidget toy ever created. Twist it, pull
it, pop it on its magnetic stand. Whenever I get in a slump at
work, I distract myself by pulling out my phone or getting up
and grabbing another cup of coffee that I definitely don't need.
Now I just grab >> Don't drink coffee. Vape, bro. Vape
>> perfume. Fidget with it a bit. Get a little stimulant
of flavor and I'm right back to work. So, come join the over
500,000 people that use Fume. And right now, if you order the
Journey Pack today using code Willy Mac, you'll get a free Fume
topper. So, if you've been thinking about changing your bad,
this is the perfect first step. So, go to
or scan the QR code to grab yours today. Thank you, Fume, for
sponsoring this >> Apparently, it's apparently it's not
a uh a vape. Mac decides to run and make a video like 2 hours
after. Okay. Well, there was there was the ad. The rest is just
his Patreon stuff. Damn.
Damn. What a what a great video. That's like shocking to me.
This this ad has been the most insightful look to the average
Willy Mack audience member. All right, dude. No,
I listen.
I don't know if he asked the cops. I kind of doubt he asked the
cops if he could he could make the video, right? If he could
announce this publicly. I think that was a little weird. I do
think um
I do think at this point though given what Destiny said that
deleting some stuff when there would be like a record of it and
also I just think in the back of my head I keep thinking about
how I've heard
>> hold on dung devil donation >> dung devil donated
$3. At this point the only legal advice I'd buy destiny ever
really being given is well they can't jail a corpse. >> Okay.
Uh can we watch this? What is
>> I joked. >> God damn it. Yeah, I'll put this on.
Um, what was I gonna say here? I was just gonna say, oh, um,
I don't know what mistakes he made. I do think, yeah, probably
contacting the cops is or sorry, uh, saying he contacted the
cops is a little weird. I do think Oh, right. I was going on
the direction of I think Tom Fury and Counterpoints and Tom have
all been told that he has already shared this via Discovery or
something with Pixie, which means that he's created artifacts
of this, copied them and sent them out. So, his whole thing where
he's like, uh, we could do anything. I I don't think that actually
works. Watch the full cinematic version. I think I have the full
C. Oh, maybe I don't. We'll watch in just a second. Where is
this here? Riyle. We got Riyle right here. Oh, Ry wants me to
look at this. Do I recognize any of these names? No, these names
aren't anything.
These are like funny kind of. Okay, Ry just sent me a couple
messages. I'm just going to read these off cuz I don't want to
show their names on stream like right after I said I' I'd think
about this. I have to see if there's any proof of like people
going after his chatters. I just can't see there being any reason
to. Um, but if there were some substantiation to that, I might
actually be a little concerned. So, I'm not going to I'm not
going to show these names. These are like food shops chatters.
They're just little messages while they were watching the Willy
Mack video. No one will ever speak with Willie off the record
again. Nice career move of him. Another one. I wonder if Willie
will ever address the fact that he made a video on off thereord
info here. Willie Mack, more like snitchy rat. He never really
cared about this.
And finally, this guy was a big old baby about his wedding, but
no has no care with how he's treating this this alleged
victim. Demented.
Yeah. No, it's not Yog. Um, PWF lift a comment on the video.
No way. Alex from playing with fire. I like your content, bro,
but I think you're crossing into reckless accusation territory.
Dest said he has what he does because he needs to for his legal
case. I'm not a lawyer, but this sounds plausible. You have no
evidence that he's lying. But take all that aside. If you were
legitimately concerned, why make the bid afterwards? At the very
least, why not wait until the police investigation concludes?
Desty is definitely a DJ, but I severely doubt he's a and implying
so is crossing into defamation.
Uh Willie didn't call him a in this video. Willie said it depends
on how pedantic you're being about it. But he did not he did
not call him a I don't believe. Yeah,
the C team is up. Bro, I don't know how PWF made the cut after
food shops. That's crazy, right? Uh oh, I also tweeted I tweeted
I tweeted the the most difficult tweet of my entire life. Okay,
I said it. Okay, it's not it's not literally zero notes, but
I'm trying not to be pedantic. Okay, this is the most difficult
tweet of my life. It's pinned in the chat. You can go retweet
it. You can like it. Okay, it's the most difficult tweet of my
life.
Okay, this does not make up at all for lying. Doesn't fix any
of that. Uh, we still need a retraction, but I am going to go
ahead and boost this video because this video is a fantastic
rebuttal to everything Dusty's been saying. The glazing is making
me sick. Hey, whoever made that video, whoever wrote that script,
they did a fantastic job, okay? Whether or not we really believe
it was Willie, I'm I'm not gonna go into it, okay? It doesn't
matter. Whoever made that video,
uh, no, no matter how fatly that video was made, okay, it's still
a great video. I don't care how fatly it was made, all right?
It was a fantastic video and we we like that video, okay? Did
Doomer come back? Welcome back, Doomer. No, just assumed Ralph
just grabbed his corpse like a puppeteer. Okay, Doomer Media
is uh is now morale. All right. Uh, no, it was fantastic. Zero
Notes, Missy Elliot. What part of that video is bad? What part
of this video specifically is bad? I actually have no notes on
that video. I actually think that video is fantastic. Oh, sure.
But hold on. That's just Hold on. This is one thing where I kind
of I I agree morally that Rose's PII being in there is bad.
But I also know that if it was not in there, Destiny would continue
to cope about why it's not real, right? He could he could try
to, you know, go and and try to fool people and say that it's
like not real. And and
he did have it in the other video as well. He had the full video
of her in the other video with her full name, I believe, that
he's now censored. But listen, unfortunately, focusing too much
on solo, saying Destiny has C on his computer.
Oh, Missy Elliot, it doesn't matter if you say on his computer
or not. This is This is just stupid. You're You're going way
too too overboard. You're going way too overboard with this.
I I think saying he has it on his computer matters 0%. He has
it in his possession. And the on my computer thing is just a
little dodge. There's notes. Yeah, but the notes are all super
pedantic. That's what I'm saying. I'm not saying there's literally
zero notes, okay? But that's just between us. I'll put on Twitter
zero notes. All right. Yeah. I think I think in this case
this is so much better in quality than any video he's put out
before this. Um I have no notes. If he put out this quality video
the whole
uh I'd still be friends with all these guys. All right. If he
put out this level of video before, I'd still be friends with
Nicholas and Willie probably. We'd all still be buddies. Okay.
The bar was not high. For she for sure Ethan will react to this
tomorrow. Oh, we'll see. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. We'll
see. The Destiny situation is unhinged. Scorched Earth. Change
the name though. Destiny is unironically stupid. Maybe change
it >> In my last video, I broke allegations. >> Nope.
Still unironically stupid, but hey. Oh, 500 dislikes. The I mean,
this is the extension, but finally I can say I'm too employed
for this. I ah Ethan pays for security for Willac's wedding and
that makes him lie about Destiny not confronting the video about
his 8-year-old Justin TV with the 8-year-old and Justin TV. Oh
yikes,
no way. Date of birth October 4th. Video date August 14th. So
at max she was like two months away from turning 18. Anyway,
this drama is so ridiculous. Even if this is technically according
to Americans, this is like putting someone on the vendor registry
for taking a drunken p on the playground in the middle of the
night. Miss Elliot, you need to lighten up. Okay, I showed one
of your tweets earlier today. Why don't you lighten up, bro?
Why don't you lighten the up? All right. Yeah, they are. Well,
they are pedantic notes, Harmony. They are pedantic notes. Except
I think that the doxing thing, but I'm I'm coming around to like
the idea that like when you don't show the PII for Rose, unfortunately,
Desi just gets wiggle room on it like and and he's just like
a total piece of [__] And maybe, you know, Willie
has confronted the infinite ring machine hypothetical and Willie
has decided that he will sacrifice Rose to stop the infinite
ring machine. Okay, he'll sacrifice Rose's privacy to stop the
infinite ring machine in its tracks. And I'm not sure, not unlike
the person who tried to stop it before, I'm not sure how I feel
about totally like going scorched earth in criticism. Oh man,
that's a DM. That's just absolutely insane to think about him
doing all of this if she was 17. Except she was already proven
to be 17 at this time. She was proven to be 17 at this time.
Do do I just say it again? She is proven to be 17 at the time
of Willie DMing her. She was proven to be 17
overunder on and Destiny stopping by stream tonight. Um, no.
He'll be coping about this Willie video. He's gonna write a whole
other thing in this Willie video and he doesn't have all of Willy's
like history ever. Oh, Willy Dming him. Willy DMing him. Willy
DMing him. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. At the time of Willy DMing
Destiny about this stuff where they have this conversation. She
was proven unequivocally to be 17 at the time they were. Yeah.
That's what I'm thinking. Is he going to write a manifesto tonight?
Are we taking another day off tomorrow or is it going to go back
to is it going to go from him talking about drama all day with
Connor to like guys I'm totally done with this drama. I think
if Destiny doesn't respond to this like he is just this video
was just complete.
Like Desi is completely ripped from this video at this point,
right? Like it's over. It's like flat out over. Oh man, do we
look at the Tom Foolery? Do we look at the Tom Foolery stuff?
Oh boy. I feel like Tom would be exactly on our page with this,
right? Destiny's not going to see his family for Labor Day. He's
going to do a 5 a.m. Coke stream. I don't think he's going to
react to this. Is there any world where you thought it would
be this good? Uh, no. I knew it would be good because
I think a lot of the other times, no offense. I think a lot of
the other times Willy's done really poor work has been because
he's clouded by like personal. I don't think this is the same.
Oh,
we called it, guys. Destiny is now the talking points are loaded
up. Did Willie Max really Didy Mac really just dox that poor
miner? Did Willie Max Didy Mac just dox her just to Destiny?
Did Willie Mac really Did he really Did he really do that? Oh
my god. It's so
It's embarrassing,
dude. Dude,
this some shameless right here. Wait. Hey, Destiny. How How'
they find out who Rose was again? How'd they find out again?
I If I If memory serves, the the By the way, the doxing info
that Willie put in his video that Destiny is virtue signaling
about is the doxing info that Destiny put into DGG chat to give
to Kiwi Farms. Okay. He put in a public chat to give that info
that Willie put on the screen to KF, her college name, the picture
of her in the shirt.
Like, and unfortunately, Willie is just proving that, sorry,
Destiny is proving that that had to be done. I guess that Willie
that Desi is just such a lying, manipulative piece of [__]
that if you don't show all the evidence, people won't believe
you. He'll go, "Oh, it's on Kiwi Farms." Well, guess what? Willie
just put that on YouTube. Unlucky, bro. Dude. Oh, it's just brutal.
It's brutal. Okay. All right. What else do we got on the docket
today? I think I had some other stuff in the docket today. Did
I not?
Oh, Amaranth stuff. Uh
oh, I had some more chorus stuff I was going to go to, didn't
I? A little bit. Oh, I had some I had some Aerodite logs as well.
Aerodite was kind of getting trolled by people in her Discord.
I don't know if I want to pull those up because I don't like
the guy trolling her. Oh, hold on. We got We got more logs here.
More logs. More logs. More cope.
More cope. Destiny, by the way, was that original photo of her
in the DG shirt cropped in Willy's video? Because JTO has been
describing the photos her wearing nothing but a DG shirt when
referencing it before. JTO will lie about anything he can. So,
no clue. Destiny, you posted the photo. So, no clue. You posted
the [__] photo. Well, why not just say yes or no?
What do you mean no clue? He's the guy. He's the dude. Imagine
Imagine somebody Okay, Destiny's like he's a piece of paper.
Okay. out of your sight. He writes a number on it. It's the number
seven. Okay. He passes it over to somebody else. You watch him
write the number. Okay. Uh I pick up that piece of paper. I say,
"Oh, this is the number seven." And then MVTT says, "Destiny,
JTO just said, "You wrote the number seven on that napkin." And
Destiny goes, "Ah, JTO will lie about anything. I have no idea
what I wrote on that. I have no idea.